in 2009 mayam biic revealed that she
hadn't vaccinated her two children after
conducting research and having
discussions with their pediatrician more
recently biic said her kids are now
vaccinated but don't have as many as the
average American child her commentary on
other matters also landed her in hot
water these included her remarks that
powerful ill-intentioned men like Harvey
Weinstein overlooked her because her
appearance didn't represent the standard
for beauty in Hollywood theic later
issued an apology for the comment
claiming she never meant to make
Weinstein's victims feel as if they
brought his actions on themselves due to
their look the actor wrote on X formerly
known as Twitter you are never
responsible for being assaulted I truly
sorry for causing so much pain and I
hope you can all forgive me